so Donald Trump has been not hugely
shockingly saying that Russia should be
allowed back into the g7 which would of
course return it to being the g8 and
Russia was previously kicked out of the
g8 because as you might remember Russia
annexed after invading Crimea Trump
apparently doesn't care and he's been
saying that Russia should be allowed
back into the g8 so right before Donald
Trump left to Singapore from Canada the
site of the recent g7 meeting a couple
of days ago he was asked about his
opinion on the situation with Crimea and
with Russia getting back into the g7 and
Donald Trump effectively said that's
something you should talk to President
Obama about which is a weird thing to
say when you claim that President Obama
did everything wrong but nevertheless
here's Donald Trump explaining it to
Russia for a second there's something
that happened that got him kicked out of
the g8 was the invasion an annexation of
Crimea do you think that Crimea should
be recognized at Russia at this point
because he was the one that let Crimea
get away that was during his
administration and he was the one that
let Russia go and spend a lot of money
on Crimea because they've spent a lot of
money on rebuilding and I guess they
have their submarine port there it sank
but Crimea was let go during the Obama
administration and you know Obama can
say all he wants but he allowed Russia
to take Crimea I may have had a much
different attitude but so you'd really
have to ask that question to President
Obama you know why did he do that why
did he do that but with that being said
it's been done a long time Syria in the
g8 as opposed to the g7 I would say that
the g8 that's the best Trump would
prefer Russia be part of the g8 instead
of the g7 well yeah I mean if Russia
comes back then there would be eight
countries but that's more of a
linguistic analysis I guess not never
not really a geopolitical one so the the
geopolitical question is and it's I mean
Trump is is mentioning this sort of out
of reflexive ignorance but it's an
interesting question which is are things
done by other countries irrelevant if
someone else was the president at the
time because basically what
Trump is saying is since Obama didn't
stop Russia from trait taking Crimea how
am I going to hold them accountable and
say they shouldn't be in the g8 I mean
Obama is the one who didn't stop them
from taking Crimea so not only does
Trump not have to issue a statement
about it he also doesn't even have to
hold them accountable and can say listen
I didn't allow them to do anything so
they should be part of the g8 which is
hilarious logic right because if Obama
did the wrong thing by letting Russia
take Crimea which again Trump is sort of
alluding to but not actually saying why
wouldn't Trump be punishing Russia for
it right if Donald Trump thinks that it
was incorrect what Russia did and that
they got away unscathed during the
presidency of Barack Obama well he has
an opportunity here to actually affect
some consequences like saying no Russia
shouldn't be in the g8 but of course
that's not what he's saying he's saying
since Obama allowed it we're just not
really going to hold Russia responsible
for this entire thing and meanwhile he
says that Canada is a national security
risk because he wrongly believes they
burned down the White House in 1812
wouldn't that by applying the same logic
be James Madison's fault then like why
why does Trump punish Canada today for
something he thinks they did in 1812
which of course they didn't but say that
he can't punish Russia for something
Obama did just a few years ago like I'm
not really understanding what the logic
is probably because there is no logic
whatsoever how is this an acceptable
answer from a president right rather
than fixing something or even offering
an opinion he says that's something
you've got to talk to Obama about
because it has nothing to do with me as
president of the United States and of
course that is a very strange and
childish way to look at the issue of
geopolitics but I guess if we read
between the lines since Trump only
talked about Obama the answer is that
yes he wholeheartedly wants Russia back
in the g8 and he has no plan whatsoever
to hold them accountable for Crimea and
Crimea is now Russia so congratulations
to Vladimir Putin
got away with it and Trump has
absolutely no interest whatsoever in
holding anybody accountable for it